want to achieve any goal it starts with
a two-minute blueprint in this video
I'll show you how to rewire your brain
for Success using identity first
thinking instead of focusing on what you
need to do focus on who you need to
become want to get fit don't say I need
to go to the gym say I am someone who
takes care of their body but that's just
the start I'll reveal how to use Mental
contrasting visualizing your success and
the obstacles to create a realistic road
map plus the power of minimum viable
progress starting so small it's
impossible to fail read one page do one
push-up these tiny actions rewire your
brain's identity map and here's the game
changer Temptation bundling pair
something you need to do with something
you want to do love podcasts only listen
while exercising your environment should
make success the path of least
resistance ready to unlock the secrets
to achieving literally any goal watch
the full video to learn learn how to
turn these strategies into automatic
habits and transform your life your
future self will thank you